[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
TV tonight on PBG un sensor Captain to
Tom Moore became a global hero during
the pandemic his family stands accused
of tarnishing his legacy tonight
exclusively they respond we should have
done it in a different way when I first
walk in the first thing I see is a
luxurious barle that's got nothing to do
with Captain Tom was never intended to
be the captain Tom Foundation Building
or anything like that articulate how
it's been utterly devastating and how
much were you paid I was paid £18,000
for that the only question is whether
you should have pocketed the
[Music]
cash good evening from London and
welcome to a special edition of
uncensored a world exclusive interview
with the embattle family of Captain to
Tom
Moore tomorrow will be a good day he
said and like him it was just what we
needed in our darkest hour Captain Tom
Moore was a hero of the pandemic he won
the nation's Heart by walking a 100
lamps of his garden in lockdown raising
38 million pounds at NHS
charties the whole world loved him the
late Queen knighted him and when his
foundation launched it looked set to
become a philanthropic Force but the
100-year-old war hero died with coid in
2021 now his family stands accused of
failing to protect his legacy and
enriching themselves using Captain Tom's
name Hannah Ingram Moore is a Charity's
co-founder his daughter she's been
criticized for her salary as well as big
payments for public appearances the
charity commission is investigating
conflicts of interest between the
foundation and family businesses most
incend of all they added a home Spa to a
foundational building in the grounds of
a listed home and they're fighting plans
to tear it down the family insists
they've done nothing wrong they want to
help the world in Captain sat's good
name but is that already too
late Hannah Colin Georgia Benji thank
you very much indeed for sitting down
with me Hann let me ask you straight off
the bat why have you agreed to do this
interview what do you hope to get out of
this I think um P you know you've been
on this journey with us since almost the
very beginning back in those early days
of 2020 in lockdown when the world um
started talking to my father and um of
course with all the love that comes with
something like that and there really was
love Global Adoration of him and
everything that he'd done to give hope
to the world there was always an
underbelly of hate but we um we lived
with it because in fact what he was
doing is he was giving hope to the world
and all we wanted to do was support him
to do that what did that underbelly of
hate look like it never genuinely
occurred to us and maybe that seems
foolish but it never occurred to us that
anyone could hate um um a 100-year old
man walking up and down to support the
NHS and the family behind doing
everything they could to support him and
so when it first happened I remember it
was Benji who said to me Mom you might
not want to look on your Twitter I think
it was and um I said why and he said
because it's horrible and I think the
shock the Deep shock that people were
saying
um you're have to bleep this out if you
need to they were saying bit should die
um she should be yeah she should be
jailed for um harming the elderly bet
she's got a cattle BR taking her father
around the garden hope the whole family
get Co and die including him and it went
on and on and on and on um one day I we
were doing 30 interviews a day not
because we wanted to but for love and
for Hope and we got a call and um I
think you said Hannah can you come
quickly we've got an interview to do I
was in my workshirt that had the company
logo on it so I ran to do it to be with
my father and the hate that came after
that there she is trying to manipulate
um life to get her business in the
spotlight it had never been anything of
the sort so we even colen and I sat
there and thought maybe I have to stop
being a director of our business because
maybe the campaign of hate is going to
be so damaging we'll never recover from
it I mean I've got some of the emails
that you were receiving you kept them me
Colin these some aimed at you and some
are aim to uh to the foundation but you
know this one just a sleazy pair of pwn
slime parasites fleecing people on the
back of an old man's heroism he must be
turning in his grave at the disgusting
parasitic leech called his daughter hope
you all get coid and disappear for good
this is someone who's put his actual
name here and his email right I mean
when you see that Colin what are you
feeling I think it's just disgusting I
mean it's it's been horrendous this this
was to be clear this was in July this
year after all the media coverage of the
stuff that's been going we will come to
the specifics about that but just this
reaction and it goes on I mean there's
so many of these Captain Tom a true
gentleman inspiration to Millions his
daughter a disgusting parasitic pwn
slime the morals of a dead slug
and so it goes on I mean I can't really
believe what I'm reading here I know I
mean i' I've this is your wife they're
talking about yeah I know and I well my
family yeah and we've I've spent many
years in rugby clubs and Heard lots of
language but all in one sentence and to
the and very personal and individual to
particularly to Hannah uh it's just
totally unacceptable and though you try
not to read it you can't avoid it well
this one is a letter addressed to you
Georgia yeah and you know you're 14
years old I have a young daughter nearly
12 so I can't even imagine what this
must have been like but it was to Benji
and Georgia are you aware that your
parents your mother more than your
father is a vile greedy bleep a vile
disease greedy greedy
bleep with a copy of a of a newspaper
story about what's been going on when
you received this what did you think at
first I thought it was from my friends
saying oh I'm so excited to see you back
at school and stuff and then my dad took
it and like oh don't read it just don't
and then I said oh no I really want to
read it and then I was like oh that's
ridiculous why would someone say
that I mean the idea pah that someone
would take the trouble to write a letter
to your
daughter here to this to this
address as her mother what does that
make you feel oh it's devastating this
is a pretty pink envelope with unicorns
and hearts on it deliberately done so
that we wouldn't see it so that Georgia
might pick it up innocently and open it
you would think it was a lovely little
letter from her friend like candy blush
on the back handwritten handwritten you
would absolutely never think in a
million years that the content would be
like it was but something when it
came I remember remember saying wait
because something about it because
mostly you know that the children
georg's age they're speaking on Snapchat
um so there aren't many letters that
come and when I saw it I immediately
said to Colin wait I think you need to
open it but have you had death threats
as a f yeah yeah yeah you all
immediately said yeah absolutely
specific death threat some you know some
to her some into to George and me some
into to Dad to all of us individually
together everything they set up there's
a forum and in all honesty I I tell you
these things because I've been told that
they're there I don't look because I I
think if I looked I well you wouldn't be
able to cope that is so there's a forum
that they found where they were um a
group of whatever they do on the forums
then um they were all discussing how
they were going to come and kill us all
in our beds um with pitchforks and and
Hammers and um firebomb our house yeah
we know from what's happened to Holly
Willoughby yes in the last week that
actually some of these people can be
deadly serious scary have you reported
these threats to the police yeah has
anything happened because of it they're
aware of it and under the harassment act
we've got a a log which is go all
identified so if it becomes persistent
we can we can or they can then follow
that
up
[Applause]
[Music]
last time I saw you all was at when I
did live stories uh my show with Captain
Tom and it was honestly one of my
all-time favorites and he was amazing I
mean yeah yeah 100 years old I managed
to sit through like a 2hour record he
was so funny Charming intelligent had
great stories everyone loved him um it
seems you know there's a picture of him
with the queen
here Here Yeah Yeah from the interview
but also one of when you all went up for
his Knighthood I mean that moment when
he got his Knighthood from the queen
that must have been I'm I'm sorry P but
that was even better yeah yeah that was
even better yeah but I mean that was an
amazing thing and and you know what do
it feel like as a family Hannah for you
all to to be there and meet the queen
and have her tap him on the shoulder it
was magic and I remember us being in the
car going down and um um I turned to him
and said nervous feeling okay and he
went not at all in the way that you
could imagine we felt our roles were
just as his backup and what was amazing
though and I think that people didn't
know is that the queen had asked to see
all of us um so we weren't there in our
ordinary sort of behind the scenes roles
we were there to stand with him what did
she say to you guys the queen well you
remember yeah yeah yeah she talked to
you about dogs or and as well yeah about
what year I'm in how I'm joining it and
online learning it was like being a
grandmother talking to her grand she was
the nation's grandmother yeah yeah but
she saw him and I in some of our photos
you will see it she saw him and it was
two people from the same
generation their eyes met and she smiled
in a honestly it was just amazing to see
him kned at the age of 100
and it was I I think he if he died the
next day he'd been happy um it meant
everything to him what's incredible is
that that all happened because just
outside here the famous walk because
he'd been unwell he' had a bad fall he'
broken some ribs and hurt his lung and
so on and he decided to try and get a
bit fitter and was going to walk a
hundred laps and you were going to give
him a pound a lap I think right and you
just told the local paper cuz he was
also about to turn 100 you thought was a
nice story in the pandemic and then
suddenly it gets picked up by the local
media then the national media I remember
I was on Good Morning Britain and we
interviewed you guys and then that was
on the first week and then suddenly this
thing explodes what is it like for you
guys sitting here as a regular family
you'd lived with your grandfather for 13
years here leading a perfectly normal
under the radar life and suddenly you've
got the entire world willing on your
grandfather with this walk I think it's
incredibly difficult to put it into
words cuz genuinely it was the first
weekend of lockdown this was something
as part of his rehabilitation program
that you know being the yorkman himself
always wanted to do and he was really
ill really ill to a point we we
generally thought we would lose him only
a year prior and he had that gr he had
that determination as a yorkman to go
and do this but it was the first weekend
of lockdown everyone was a bit stuffed
on what they were going to do and as
much as he gave hope to us when he
started that walk he he evidently gave
it to the nation but as we crept up the
interviews every day 30 interviews a day
raising 3 million a day it it just
becomes utterly surreal and Georgia I
mean this is your granddad right and
suddenly the whole world knows who your
granddad is that's weird it is quite
weird even some of my teachers like wait
isn't that your granddad I'm like yeah
it is that's so cool you must have been
incredibly proud of him I was really
proud of him because he achieved so much
in a little amount of time before uh he
died yeah you took him to Barbados and
it got a bit of criticism hand of this
that because he was he died two months
later it turned out he'd had pneumonia I
think on the trip to Barbados and then
he got coid and the pneumonia probably
reduced his ability to fight the co and
it very sadly killed him he was over a
hundred so you know this was not an
unexpected shock as to think for the
family that he would at some stage uh
pass but the criticism that came your
way that you should never have taken him
to Barbados uh that that was a
contributing factor to his death what
what do you feel about that it was his
dream um Barbados if you go back in time
he was interviewed I I can't remember
which newspaper said what's on your
bucket list Captain Tom and he wanted to
go back to India um he wanted to jump
out of an airplane attached to somebody
and a parachute um and he wanted to um
go and watch The Cricket in Barbados
and Barbados tourist board and their
prime minister were quick Off the Mark
and this was back in um very early very
early yeah in in 20 in in the in the
second week of um his walk so he said
yes please he'd love to go we just
couldn't go because we were in multiple
lockdowns finally we found a period of
time when we could all go and we were
all invited and his dream was to go uh
to go and see the cricketers in Barbados
and you got a cricket B over there
signed by amazing oh yeah West Indian
legends Gary so Garfield soers Wes Hall
Joel Garner Gordon Greenwich I mean I'm
a cric fan these are some of the
greatest cricketers ever play the
gameing were you concerned about him not
being physically able to make the trip
not at all in fact we had um doctors to
to check and they said go Captain Tom
enjoy it be happy no one knew how long
he was going to live we also didn't know
that he had silent pneumonia nor did
they um but nonetheless we we got on the
plane and then we have photos of him on
the plane it he he was having he was
treated like a king we'd had to take
tests Co tests before we left when we
arrived we were quarantined immediately
so we were then put in um a place where
there were CCTV in the house that we
were in we could not go outside until
we'd been cleared Again by another test
test so we know that um he was healthy
and that we didn't break lockdown rules
and that we were also not coid positive
I mean the criticism and it was the
first time I'd really seen that was well
you all got a great holiday out of it
too so all right for Tom to live his
dream but you're all getting in this
lovely free holiday in
Barbados because it was a pandemic
people annoyed perhaps that they
couldn't travel whatever you know that
you know the argument that came that way
did you consider any of
that we we paid the first week was at
the guest of barbad stor board but after
that we paid for it it was paid for by
us so it wasn't free when I interviewed
the life stories he loved all the
attention he loved it he loved being a
star he lived his life anonymously for
199 years and suddenly he's a superstar
and he loved it I I knew that um but
what it showed me was there was now a
rising appetite for looking at ways to
attack you as a family he died several
months later I would imagine after all
you'd all been through to lose him even
though he was 100 years old still a
massive blow and it must be even now
very strange to be in this house without
him yeah we were a family of five you
know for 13 years one of the things that
we've never quite been able to do is
probably to grieve as a a family um
because we grieved of the world um but
we didn't really because there was so
much going on after he passed um that we
didn't really have the chance to just
close the door sit down quietly
reflect think about all the good times
that we had with him we did of course
but not as not without being in the the
glare of the media and everything Hannah
what were your last words with your dad
uh it was amazing actually it was Benji
and I were there um and we we stayed
with him and he was really with it to to
probably the last few hours and um
there's some things of course I can
never repeat because he was quite funny
and and sometimes quite cheeky um but I
ran down a list of people who he'd like
to speak to of course I can't tell you
the answers to any of this but I'd run
down the list and he'd say definitely
not I hope I
[Music]
and um and then he'd say okay yes to
that one yes to that one absolutely not
to that one and um so we we had a bit of
fun right to the end what were the last
things that you just you chatted to with
your grandfather H as said I keep as
much of it private as possible but for
him I think he was just saying go go do
your thing you know be proud of what
you're doing continue George and me
continue doing amazing things and how
proud he was of all of us and that for
us was such a special moment cuz we
really um we really had lived with him
close and he was a really tight part of
the family you must all miss him Georgia
terribly amazing character I miss him
terribly CU after Sports we would go
chat about sports how if I got really
angry he would say why why would you why
did you get angry we'll sort it out
practice and practice we'll watch
something on the TV to sort out sort it
out we'll go and paint something just to
make you forget about
it good evening I'm Pi Morgan I'm
sensored in New York City King pi and
King Q I think there's only room for one
king man you know what I'm saying he's
mocked your weight Trump yeah look at
him fail St working just cuz they're
skin folk don't mean they're kin Folk
believe you can win this war you making
me cry again they're trying to force you
out yes I feel betray keep it
awardwinning l Ley will die behind bars
and a senior Doctor Who first raised
concerns about Ley once NHS manages to
be regulated we needed answers a lot
sooner this is what seven years down the
line I mean it's completely ludicrous he
was clearly something of the face of the
W so even more Unthinkable if this nurse
had misgendered somebody on a board she'
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
wey K that would make her a better
princess of wealth cuz you're not just
marrying the man you're marrying the job
that resonates with people gay Maxwell
agreed to be interviewed for the very
first time I he wish I'd never met him
the conservative party can certainly win
the next election can we lab 29 imag the
can we did he say yes I have taken drugs
and they bent the rules or lied on the
visa application form and therefore got
it
there needs to be an intervention around
abortion laws Parliament is Sovereign
Parliament can determine these things
the rest of the world has watched on in
sort of mounting horror as this story
has unraveled for you it was incredibly
personal the death toll from the Titanic
tragedy has risen to 1522 and may God
Rest their
[Music]
souls
Let It
Roll yes if we stop producing oil the
knock on effect is far larger than just
CO2 I nearly have empathy when I'm
speaking to them I know know you're
probably going to boot me after show
send
this some of them they're easily
LD you can kiss my American
ass thank you very much very nice of you
Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my hand thank
you there's a threat that you'd be
worried about so are you saying that
you're being overwhelmed that you're
inundated we are really working hard for
you we're just asking patients to be
patient with
us we're now in Barbie world you weren't
asked to give evidence to the Grand
jurry I'm the only one that has been
telling the truth you don't drink never
taken drugs you're stinking Rich should
we be
concerned if it's on your mind it's on
talk TV is about you and your opinions
if you you're thinking about it we're
talking about
it it's all about me that's a
[Music]
joke this is talk
TV welcome back to unsensed and my
exclusive interview with the family of
Captain saton Mo you always said
tomorrow will be a good day and Hannah
It's been a IAL number of days for you
as a family actually since then and a
lot of it is centered around these
issues surrounding the Captain Tom
Foundation the charity you set up in his
memory um and various other parts uh of
the pie around there so let's go through
some of this let's start with this
building because this is the Captain Tom
Foundation Building and as we sit uh
you're waiting to hear in two or three
weeks as to whether this has to to be
knocked down or not let's go back to the
start of this when you first applied for
planning permission for this what was
the purpose what did you want this to be
so you have to go back a little bit in
time um people will have seen when he
was walking that we had um a small above
ground pool on the driveway and when um
he had fallen and broken his hip and um
was terribly ill he came home and wanted
to rehabilitate and he'd said I fancy um
walking up and down inside the pool
we're never going to get you in there
that was the foundations of well maybe
we can get one of those pools where you
can walk against um the resistance of
but it never happened because of coid so
this started way back this wasn't just
something we did there was an intention
to have that for him and then what
happened we had 225,000 birthday cards
arrive which are stored um in London at
at quite a large cost to us on top of of
that thousands of things thousands of
things that are stored in another three
other plac I've seen boxes and boxes of
St that's just the stuff tiny amount
that's a fraction of it so we it was
also taking over our house and taking
over rooms in our office so we said look
why don't we reenter it so that we can
have somewhere to put all of those
things because also those cards two
125,000 birthday cards we haven't
recycled them or got rid of them because
we feel they have a place in as part of
the nation so this isn't doing things
selfishly it's about how can we preserve
what did you want this building to be to
be Mally yeah just purely that some
storage multi-purpose to be able to put
some of his things in it some of his
memorabilia we also wanted to um have it
as a community building so that we could
help some of the local aging population
maybe we could have some Pilates classes
up here maybe they could come and do
what my father couldn't do and walk up
and down in the resistance pool and also
have meetings um because this is the
perfect place when talking about the
Legacy that my father's left of that
incredible Legacy of a world without
agism and okay so that's the original
plan and that gets approved by the
council yes uh but then you make another
submission and this time you wanted to
add a spa pool which is what I've Just
Seen around the corner which is you know
it's quite a big Spa pool um why why did
you need to have that well that was the
historical part so we we bought it CU we
talked about doing it with my father but
he's already given the heer died by the
time you did this so why did you want to
add the spa here as a family because we
because we wanted it as part of that
Legacy and because it was a nice thing
to do I think that was a mistake I think
that was always going to attract and the
original plan yeah I mean I've been
walking around here and the memorability
is incredible from the The cricet
memorability Joe roots shirt Michael
bnes England Blazer you know to the
pictures here and incredible
stuff but it's very hard to argue that
you need a spar pool to pay tribute to
your father and it's very hard to argue
that whatever the original plan in your
heads that he would be able to use it
obviously once he died that argument's
gone too I just don't think you should
have done the spa pool and I think
that's what angered the public because
they're like how does that add anything
to the memory of that looks like you are
giving yourselves as a family a nice
little treat but you're using the
Captain Tom Foundation umbrella to
justify it that would be what I would
say to you yeah and I think look
everyone can look in hindsight and our
original application the the name was
never intended to be the captain Tom
Foundation it was supposed to be the
captain Tom building it got lost in
translation and we take responsibility
for that completely because the original
application does name check Captain Tom
Foundation a lot it it does so it looks
like the
foundation is somehow approving of this
but it turned out they were not
approving of it no and this building was
not to do with the charity it was where
we could use it for charitable do you do
you accept that you should have at the
very least told the foundation and
sought their approval for it if you were
going to use the name of the foundation
for the application I think we
absolutely didn't intend it to be the
captain Tom Foundation it and it
shouldn't have been and we should have
checked it and we should have made sure
it didn't say that so we completely
accept responsibility for it because the
purpose of the building is multi-purpose
for office use for meetings and when you
look at the part where we've covered
that pool we could have left it
uncovered we could and and hindsight
says
that we probably should have um so we
have to accept that we made a decision
and it was probably the wrong one I
think you just you played into your
critic's hands yeah right Colin I just
think that when I came in I thought I
wonder how big that is you know what
it's pretty nice it's something most
people can't afford it's an expensive
luxurious thing it has really nothing to
do with uh Captain Tom or his legacy or
anything actually it's purely just a
nice thing for you to have as a family
but you were applying as the Captain Tom
Foundation to do it that's what Ang was
certainly a statement from the
foundation said they were not happy
about that they weren't involved but
secondly just public opinion we accept
that we accept it we you know we were
caught up with trying to get the the
building to do what we wanted it to do
um we should have C you know we wanted
to leave the name of Captain Tom here as
a legacy and we should
have done it in a different way and
without any doubt and you know we we've
suffered as a result um a lot of the
locals Benji they've also been angered
by this they also think the building
itself is a bit of an eyes saw but it's
just an aesthetic detail of this but do
you I mean do you agree that the The
Spar thing has just goed people into
thinking maybe not what you intended at
all but that actually you were
benefiting from this yeah what I hope
people understand as well is we did not
use charity money for this it may have
you know hindsight we shouldn't have
called it a capon Foundation Building it
slipped through the net and that is
responsibility we take but never once
that we use money from the foundation
and I hope people can can understand
that part of it and also the isol thing
granted when you build something people
are going to have objections to it and
what I hope they understand is it's also
not finished we haven't finished it I
think no I think I think Hannah I think
the thing about this is if it genuinely
was a kind of Museum to your father I
think people would accept that they
might want some tweaks to the design or
whatever it may be I think it's that has
been the problem and I think it's also
it's a grade two listed building your
property here I have one of those I know
how difficult it is to get anything onto
a grade two listed site and the again
the criticism is that you use the
Captain Tom Foundation name repeatedly
in the application almost Mak Mak it
very difficult for the council not to
approve it and they did approve it and
then you add this other stuff which is
clearly not part of any kind of Museum
that's really where we are with this
aren't we I think so and and again we
what we talked about was to um have
charity meetings here it was never
intended to be the captain Tom
Foundation Building where it would house
staff or anything like that but look
hindsight is is a wonderful thing and we
should have been more careful and we
should have done this
differently
[Applause]
[Music]
y
have you offered to get rid of the barle
we're we're in the appeal of process of
appeal so we are going through the
process but would do you not think it
might be Colin just good Optics to say
regardless of whatever the council say
that was a bad idea we're going to get
rid of it at the moment where we're at
is if we lose the appeal the whole
building has to get demolished right um
and obviously any compromise in between
that will have to have a look at but
that is that is the position and that
would be a great
shame one neighbor told the Daily Mail I
knew Captain Tom quite well he would
have hated what's gone on here what do
you feel when he would um you know we
thought we had really good relationships
with the neighbors um it's been
unfortunate that they taken a a stance
they've um but we would we wouldn't want
that to happen you know the village has
been fantastic to us um and really you
know there are certain people in the
village that have gone way over and
above and beyond and and you know we've
done an awful lot for the village as
well over the years and we you know we
were quite sad to see all of that and we
we wouldn't want it and maybe you know
they wouldn't want it either Hannah
who's paid for this
building we have we have all personal
money all personal money so not a penny
has come from any money that was raised
in your father's name not one penny
that's category there's no there'll be
no paper trail there'll be no paper tra
it's entirely your entirely see that's
why again I just ask you one more time
because I think it's important
regardless of what the council decide
with this appeal and they may decide to
raise the whole thing in which case this
becomes a moot point but if they don't
do you not think it would be a good idea
to get rid of that
sparle honestly I think that how I feel
about this whole thing now is just
sorrow because um in a week's time um
that judgment will be made so I want to
think of we've just got to deal with it
and it's more I'm thinking I'm more
about the Optics and public opinion but
we might not have a choice right you
might not the choice might not be yours
but right now you have a choice about
how you view that and it seems to me you
do regret it you do understand why
people haven't liked the fact you use
the foundation name to process this
application and then put a spar pool in
it might go some way to dissipate the
criticism to say regardless of what the
council decide we understand now the
anger that's created and we're going to
get rid of that pool we're going to make
it more of what the rest of this
building is a genuine Museum to your
father yeah I I think if if it goes
against us then we've got to look at the
whole the whole building and see you
know I mean how we could redesign it
because obviously the the facilities are
out there but why don't you just say
Colin we're going to get rid of the
pool what have we we have to see what
happens but the only op you don't it's
your pool yeah you could be ordered to
raise it all yeah which might happen
which is the only but right now for the
purposes of this interview given that
you accept it was a mistake I would
offer you the chance to say regardless
we're going to get rid of it so we'll
have to honestly Pi we will have to look
at how we can redesign the building and
the roof structure to why are you
reluctant to say you'll get rid of it
well because we haven't looked at that
as an option because at the moment it's
a black and white situation of either or
and we haven't looked at in order to
redesign it we'll have to look at how I
would say if I'm watching this andn I'm
like come on you know everybody hates
that pool you know why they hate it you
know really you shouldn't have done it
the way you did it you know you
shouldn't have used the foundation's
name to do this just we understand that
and we're going to get rid of it because
we believe there should be a legacy to
your father and
we know that that is what's caused a lot
of anger and if we had options that
would definitely be one of them well
that it's always an option you just get
rid of it no it's not because our when
we go to appeal it's keep it or or tear
it all down right there isn't a but even
if you get allowed to keep it I would
say get rid of it well if we are allowed
to keep it we will we will talk about
what we're allowed to do in if you want
to keep light of all the it may be
absolutely one of the conditions I
understand that but I'm not talking
about what the council decid I'm talking
about do you actually want to keep it
now I given all the aggravation it's
caused and given to me is pretty
indefensible given what your plan was
for this building that's really the
point I'm making should you not just say
we get it it's wrong we didn't think
this through properly and we're going to
get rid of it you have a chance now
before anybody else makes that decision
for you if you want to do that I think
we would sit down and decide what we
want to do I the actual pool itself I I
the thing that is has made people angry
and the reason and we know we did this
wrong is we covered it we built over it
and the compromised solution of course
is to have it just in situe outside
without being covered well well to be
clear the Chari trustees said at no time
were the Captain Tom foundation's
independent trust trustees aware of
planning permissions made by Mr and Mrs
Ingram Moore purporting to be in the
foundation's name had they been aware of
any applications the independent
trustees would not have authorized them
so it's not quite as straightforward as
that they wouldn't have authorized them
if they'd known and you were using the
foundation name for the planning
permission
application and that's why I simply come
back to when I walked around here I feel
my heart well about this amazing guy and
I love what you've begun to do here as a
tribute to him and I could imagine
people wanting to come and see
it but when I first walk in the first
thing I see is a luxurious far poool
that's got nothing to do with Captain
Tom at
all and yet you use the Captain Tom
Foundation name to get it and that's why
I'm
surprised that given I've asked this a
few times now you don't just say
actually we get get it that's going to
go regardless of whatever the council
says so I'll give you one last chance
then then we'll move on but it's I think
it's important I think though that I
can't possibly answer that before we as
a family would sit down and discuss it
what do you think George as my mom said
earlier my granddad really wanted to
walk in the pool sure but he he can't
but other people can yeah and that's the
and and the whole part of this
application is that the community peace
and uh we've had that Community piece at
the heart of it and and that's why I try
really hard not to react um negatively
to this because the purpose of the
building is to allow the community to
enjoy it and that was the heart and soul
behind this and it's not that this is a
museum but our whole purpose was that my
father couldn't walk in that amazing
resistance pool which in the end is a 5
m by 2 me a p but other people can um
part of the Aging population can we have
a Pilatus teacher who's waiting for this
space to be authorized so she can do
Pilates classes for our aging population
so until those dreams are dead until
we've been told you can't do any and see
again I don't want to be cynical but I
don't think that was the main motivation
for that pull I think the main
motivation was you wanted a nice barp as
a family to use yourselves of course but
part of about whether other old people
are going to come in and use it I think
you guys wanted to use it yourselves and
that's fair enough right you're entitled
to spend your money however you want to
spend it by the way right if it's your
money that PID for all this it's your
call yes this is not a legal thing right
this is just a I guess it's a moral
thing it's whether you feel comfortable
given the furor that the first thing
people come into when they come into the
Captain Tom Foundation Building is a
spar pool that is just a luxurious item
I I think just to correct that this now
is not the Captain Tom Foundation
Building it was done in error on the
first application on the second
application it's called the Captain Tom
and it's called the what Captain Tom
building because it's our Legacy it
doesn't have well well it's actually
because I know Callin to be fair it was
the the foundation trustees weren't even
aware of the first application so you
weren't you weren't able to use it in
the second one no so we didn't anyway so
we've but that but that's why you didn't
use it no it wasn't actually because
that it was already in 12 months before
so we corrected we we found out we'd
done that we realized we'd done it and
we corrected it so it's called Captain
Tom buly Captain Tom lived in this area
in this building in our grounds and it
was called the Captain Tom building why
do you care so much about the sparle
that you're prepared to damage your
reputations going forward just through
it seems to me slight I might be wrong
but a slight sort of well so you we're
keeping it mentality which I can
understand because of the attacks you've
had but wouldn't it just be better for
the Optics to get rid of the thing it
might be but we have to look at the
design the design of the building was
set up in such a way so we and we just
we don't want to commit to it um Hannah
you got criticized for going to
Wimbledon Tennis oh yes um and I
remember watching this live actually you
were on Cent call and your father's name
got mentioned and uh you stood up and
you encouraged to by one of the wimbl
officials stand up and you took the
Applause of the crowd and in the moment
it probably seemed like a very nice
moment for you but within hours you were
getting hammered on social media because
people are say well you're not Captain
Tom what are you doing there on your own
at the center Court why are you taking
the Applause of the crowd and so on you
know what people said how did you feel
when you read that reaction it was
extraordinary we were invited colonized
as part of that Legacy
and of the recognition that of the
family doing so much to support my
father to raise that 40 million of
course if he'd been alive I would have
probably gone with him um but instead we
were invited um the two of us I had
never an intention to stand up why would
I want to do that um but I was not
encouraged I was told to because the
Applause who was it that told you that
um I can't
remember was the I think it might have
been um and I would never have stood up
but he he'd said you must stand up and
people were waving and shouting and
everything that um how do I stay silent
I feel that was unfair on me was all
right I felt that was unfair I think The
Spar pool criticism is Justified I think
that to me felt unfair you're
representing your dad you've been right
center Station the whole time you the
crowd applauded very warmly right so
they clearly didn't have a problem with
you being there and you stood up and you
thanked them and that was it was a nice
moment I thought um well it was amazing
and of course if someone's waving how I
thought it was so rude not to wave back
that's all that I did let's talk about
the when you become CEO of the
foundation and you put
forward that you want to be paid I think
originally it was going to be three days
a week and you'd be paid £65,000 a year
and then there's an application to
increase that to full-time job £100,000
a year although there is a range up to
£150,000 and you were taken advice from
people about the kind of range for a CEO
of this kind of foundation what they
might get is that an accurate
representation of what happened the
independent trustees came to me and said
would I be prepared to do that job and
and I said yes I would would be prepared
to they went away and benched marked
salary I didn't ask for anything did you
feel any
quals about taking a job which would
involve you being
paid effective I guess from public
donations because that finan is the
foundation right that because you were
his daughter actually and maybe with
hindsight this is the the question
whether it would have been much easier
for you not to have taken that job it's
really interesting isn't it because at
the time it felt like the only thing to
do um because without the injection from
the family what was it going to become
we had this incredible Legacy our desire
as a family is to ensure that Legacy
gives the greatest positive social
impact that it can do you know in
hindsight I wish I'd never done it um
but the foundation would have been much
worse off for it the problem is that
what's come soon since has practically
destroyed it but I I think all those
things hindsight is wonderful we can all
look back and think maybe we should have
done things different when the when the
charity commission refused the
foundation to let you be paid a salary
of 100,000 saying it was neither
reasonable nor Justified that must have
been a pretty difficult moment for you
but I wasn't part of that discussion
that was the independent trustees no
when you heard they were refusing to let
you be paid yes you must have know this
is going to be a story it's going to
make me look bad right it's going to
look like I'm trying to get underground
running my father's foundation and I've
now had that salary rejected for being
unreasonable unjustified it just doesn't
forget the fact that I know you right
when I first saw that I went ouch that
doesn't look good only those discussions
was I was I was never part of that 100
range whatever it was I only was offered
what I was offered right you accepted
the did what I was
offered I never ever thought that those
discussions would make it into the
public Arena ever because they were
private discussions your salary was
always going to be a public public
record yeah but but never any of the
discussions the argument was that you
had no experience that justified that
gun of salary running a huge Foundation
as chief executive officer I get the
personal part of your thinking that well
who else could have done it in your
dad's name in the way that you would
know cuz you knew him so well I get that
but I think that to expect a salary of
£100,000 of public money when you're his
daughter then it it looks bad it looks
bad it's like here's Hannah she she
wants 100,000 a year for a job she's not
really qualified to do in terms of
experience at all if you'd had a
background of running Charities it's far
more Justified but you didn't and so the
public well hang on a second she's
getting 100 Grand of our money to do
this
firstly I was never offered 100,000 I
was offered what they offered me in the
end which was not 100,000 when in the
end did a deal to pay 85 because that
was what the charity commission prepared
to accept yes you did accept 100,000
originally because that was put forward
to the charity commission I didn't ever
accept 100,000 well that's what they put
forward yeah but and I didn't know they
were going to offer me 100 I wasn't part
of that discussion those discussions are
between the trustees and the charity
commission not me you would have
accepted whatever salary they paid you
right probably yes yeah so it's a kind
of move Point well maybe it is the
charity commission said you can only pay
a maximum of 85,000 I think you went on
that on a rolling thre month scenario
while you found somebody else exactly um
I mean so you said with hindsight you
wouldn't have taken that job because it
just pulled more anro on your head right
yeah I think
um in the end I was asked to do a job
for all the right reasons and because I
do have uh knowledge of Global business
from my from my
past and you you like a marketing
director of sworts sales sales and
distribution yes some for some big
Brands yeah so I wasn't without
knowledge and I knew and we believed as
a family that um I could put the charity
on the map and um and and you know what
I did do a really good job while I was
there I got it to the point that it had
purpose and it had vision and it knew
where it was going but in hindsight no I
should have said no I'm not doing it the
commission identified potential concerns
about payments of consultancy fees and
payments to family companies in your
first year of accounts but they then
said they were satisfied these specific
payments were reasonable imbursement for
expenses incurred by the companies in
the formation of a charity um what
raised eyebrows was there were total
cost of I think it was £
55,78424 to Matrix Group limited which
is your management company set up I
think in 2010 I guess it's again the
Optics right given that it's your
management company would it have been
better with hindsight not to have had
any money come from the foundation
public money to your management company
regardless of how legitimate the EXP
if if there had been a mechanism to do
that then yes it would have been a much
more preferable situation actually for
both sides because that you know it
proved difficult for Matrix as well you
know they weren't our staff we just paid
the
money and passed it on pound for pound
to to the charity to be clear neither of
you have ever made any money directly
from the foundation for personal gain
not a penny no there's nothing that's
like that no and as we've said
um we have never been so I am a family
trustee um and I became a family trustee
12 months after the original charity was
set
up I'm a childood
accountant and I have been very specific
I was very specific right from day one
that I had absolutely no access to the
bank account I had no sign in Powers I
have never seen a checkbook never mind
uh made any payments I'm not able to
make any payments I'm not an authorized
person Hannah during her role in three
months in theory was able to authorize
payments but she never did and we were
very clear that that's not something we
should do so the independent trustees
had sole discretion as to who they paid
how it was paid and when it was paid we
have never ever had a penny out of that
good evening I'm Pi Morgan uncensored in
New York City King pi and King QBE I
think there's only room for one king man
you know what I'm saying he's mocked
your weight Trump yeah look at him fail
not working just cuz they're skin folk
don't mean they're kin folk do you
believe you can win this War you making
me cry again they're trying to force you
out yes I feel betrayed keep it award
winning Lucy Ley will die behind bars
and a senior Doctor Who first raised
concerns about Ley wants NHS manages to
be regulated we needed answers a lot
sooner this is what 7 years down the
line I mean it's completely ludicrous it
was clearly something of the face of the
ward so it's even more Unthinkable if
this nurse had misgendered somebody on a
ward she'd have been out the door when
they first got together there were press
stories weighty Katy that would make her
a better princess of wealth cuz you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people gay Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I he
wish I'd never met him the conservative
party can certainly win the next
election can we lab
29 the can we did he say yes I have
taken drugs and they bent the rules or
lied on the visa application form and
therefore got it then needs to be an
intervention around abortion laws
Parliament is Sovereign Parliament can
determine these things the rest of the
world has watched on in sort of mounting
horror as this story has unraveled for
you it was incredibly personal the death
toll from the Titanic tragedy has risen
to 1522 and may God Rest their
[Music]
souls Let It
Roll y yes if we stop producing oil the
knock on effect is far larger than just
CO2 I nearly have empathy when I'm
speaking to them I know now you're
probably going to boot me off to
show Mark some of them they're easily
lit you can kiss my American
ass thank you very much very nice of you
Twitter you sons of can you please
reinstate my hand thank you there's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with
us we're now in Barbie world you weren't
asked to give evidence to the grand jury
I'm the only one that has been telling
the truth you don't drink never taken
drugs you're stinking Rich should we be
concerned if it's on your mind it's on
talk TV is about you and your opinions
if you're thinking about it we're
talking about
it it's all about me that was a
[Music]
joke on TV on Radio and on your
smartphone this is talk
[Music]
TV welcome back to pbor on sensors
shortly before the Captain Tom
Foundation was launched Hannah and Colin
set up a private company called Club
Nook limited that company made
applications for trademarks related to S
Tom's name and his image the charity
commission says that could have
generated a significant profit for the
company and they're looking into whether
that's appropriate in my next part of my
interview the family revealed
exclusively how the company has made its
money and it's a lot of money and why
they believe it's unrelated to the
Charity's
work makes £89,000 in its first year and
after creditors were paid it was left
with just under
half a million pounds that was from the
company accounts and this uh company was
basically licensing trademark registered
names of products including beer Spirits
greting cards clothing calendars
biscuits and so on that's that's
potentially potentially so where did
that money come
from the money came from exactly that
from from from products not from
products it came from uh in using his
intellectual property right but but
where did the actual Revenue come from
as as a private company but what was the
revenue from from from those from his
assets from his Family Trust what do you
mean and from and from appearances that
he made and other things where he was
where he was occasionally paid for the
for those
activities right so Hannah were you
involved in this in the club not
business so because you were asked by
the times where the money come from and
you you didn't
answer just to clarify what that income
that 800,000 what can you be more
specific it's it's not something that we
want to talk about because it's at the
end of the day it's our our private a
lot of money it's a lot of money but we
also have SE several businesses and I
think that we shouldn't but this one was
set up
specifically to trademark your father's
name and and other business and other
business
opportunities right and those are but
where is that money gone but those are
not all entirely related to Captain Tom
there are the businesses that we have
but you know the reason I'm asking is
obvious is that people will think that
you've used your father's name in club
no limited to trademark products and
you've kept the
money is that true no I'm presuming all
the revenue that came into that has come
from trademark products that was
not all some um some what
percentage well I don't know I could say
you you are the two aren't you the two
directors yeah the majority of it the
majority of it so the majority of the
800,000 has come from selling trademark
products products associated with his
name yeah right yeah because that's the
whole point of the company right so
what's happened to that
money it has been it has been used you
know some of it was used to look after
Tom looked after
security um and and trying to look to
how we can build that in the
future right but you've kept most of it
I
guess yeah yeah it's private private
income right so this that for me is
another problem another red flag I got
to be honest because I guess that was
what the actual answer was going to be
and the public are going to think hang
on a second the family is set up this
company called Club note limited to
trademark the Captain Tom name to sell
products beers Spirits credit cards and
so on and they've kept the cash why are
the Charities not getting the cash my
father was part of all of those
discussions and that company is there in
its Essence to to protect him that's why
it was there and also from his
perspective that we had a right to live
and to to to live as well as we could
live we were hard workers and we not
shers we um have we put everything in to
everything and we're recompensed and I
think that's fair I £800,000 by flogging
of Captain Tom beer and spirits and
biscuit I think you're misleading there
that that's an as that was potentially
an aspiration to that well we got to
remember the company made
89,000 that didn't have any public
donated money so that was not public
donation was the public buying the
products the not necessarily okay but
what I would say is I mean Hannah you
said to the times Club no has not
profited from branded merchandise and
memorabilia Club no has not been paid by
the foundation for use of it trademarks
Club no's revenues been generated by
other activities I mean that's just not
true is it Club no has profit heavily
from branded merchandise and
memorabilia that statement wasn't
correct yeah it is it is correct not cuz
the club has profited to this tune of
net £500,000 from branded merchandise
it's from products that hold his name
right but it's not but that's branded
product isn't it I mean you you know
there brand new
product there all the work for for is it
I think this is a this is a a really
[Music]
um I think it's a really unfair um line
of questioning because because these are
businesses that we run they are
protecting my father's name he allowed
his name to be used in the charity um
for for charitable purposes that was it
anything else St this is not a
charitable purpose no and when you said
to the times that clubok hadn't profited
from branded merchandise that's not true
it made £89,000 in his first year from
branded merchandise can we just stop and
that's that's not about protecting but
it's all about protecting can we just
stop for a second yeah this is can weop
can we just can we stop for a second
sure and stop filming because this is
really unfair so what's unfair no so let
let us explain off off camera I'd rather
do it on camera no no no no if it's on
camera we're not doing the interview the
interview was dramatically stopped and
we had a lengthy off the record
conversation during the course of this
Hannah and Colin revealed where the
revenue had actually come from and we
agreed to go back on the record so Colin
here's what I need to establish because
this has been the issue which people
have been uh I think rightly concerned
about which is all this money this
£89,000 in the first year that Club Nook
limited raised in Revenue where did that
come from because the belief is it came
from Captain Tom themed merchandise is
that the case no that's that the money
hasn't come from merchandise the bulk of
that money the vast majority of that
money came from the three books that he
wrote um with penguin Random House the
Captain Tom wrote the the Captain Tom
wrote including one was a big runaway
number one best yeah so tomorrow will be
a good day which is his autobiography
which is about his life um and what
percentage of the club money was from
those books 95% of it so the vast
majority yeah was there any other
merchandise themed product no never any
no so Club not never made any revenue
from Captain Tom themed merchandise
outside of these books no so Hannah the
question I guess about the books
is people will say well the books are
based on his Fame which came from the
charity walks why is that money not gone
to
charity these um were my father's books
and and it was honestly such a joy for
him to write them but they were his
books they um the deal was done he had
an agent and the agent um and he worked
on that deal they were Captain Tom's
books and his wishes were that that
money was that that money would sit in
club Nook and in the end um for you to
keep yes he said that specifically to
you specifically was there anything on
any of the books that referred to the
Captain Tom Foundation absolutely not
was there anything in the contracts that
referred to Captain Tom foundation so
there was never any agreement by you on
behalf of your father with these book
deals that any of that money would go to
charity absolutely not and remember that
he wrote these books um he started
writing them fairly early on um just as
the walk had finished and they were all
signed off he'd finished them by the
June of
2020 um they they were never anything to
do with the charity what will you say to
people who will say you shouldn't have
kept that money that it should have all
gone to the Char that these books were
based on Captain Tom it's the public are
buying the books it should all gone to
Charlie what would you say to those but
they were my father's books um he wrote
them and he decided what to do with the
income from them it was his wishes not
not ours he made the decision about the
things that he did we um didn't act for
him Colin I mean people will criticize
this you know that but are you
comfortable looking back would you do
the same thing again given all the
attention that's now being put on you as
a family all the
criticism would you if you had your time
again keep that money yes you know they
were it was his money his income and
just because the charity happened to be
called Captain Tom Foundation doesn't
mean that his assets are all suddenly be
owned by the charity and I think you
know one of the things we've thought
about quite a lot is probably in
hindsight calling the foundation Captain
Tom foundation and allowing his name to
be used in that especially as a living
person
um was the wrong thing to do and we
probably you know that advice should
have come forward to us at the beginning
but it didn't and you know we've we've
come to regret it um and been associated
with a foundation and suddenly
everything is associated with the
foundation which is incorrect there will
be people who say that you shouldn't as
a family have made any money off the
back of your father including the books
including everything right what do you
say to those people Hannah but they were
his books they he might have lived for
another four or five years and that
wasn't income we took from him it was
income from his books that he loved to
write and and I suppose there'll always
be criticism we it we can't do right for
doing wrong in the end they were his and
if he was sitting here today he'd say
yes P that's exactly what we talked
about we're not making up what he wanted
he was alive um when that book deal
happened we didn't make the decisions
for him he made
them since I recorded this interview we
discovered a statement on the Charity's
website and a tweet from Captain Tom's
account which do imply that the books
could support the foundation the
Charities mentioned in one of the books
and the prologue to his autobiography
says this astonishingly at my age with
the offer to write this Memoir I've also
been given the chance to raise even more
money for the charitable Foundation now
established in my name two more books
were published after his death in 2021
one offering A1 pound donation to the
foundation for each book sold and
whether any of this broke any rules will
ultimately be for the charity commission
to
decide
[Music]
[Applause]
I
[Music]
Hannah let me ask you about another
another thing which caused criticism
this is where you've appeared at award
ceremonies the Virgin Media O2 Captain
Tom Foundation connector Awards which
included the name of the charity and the
Charity's logo on its award Parks you
were at the time the interim chief
executive uh of the foundation but your
fee wasn't paid to the foundation but to
The Matrix Group is that correct yes and
how much were you paid for these Awards
um well the charity got a donation and I
was paid £18,000 for that once only or
was it once so you were paid
£8,000 and how much did the charity get
£2,000
2,000 the criticism again is obvious
which is that you shouldn't have been
paid this is your father's Foundation
Award and set up in his name you're the
foundation chief executive why you
getting paid £18,000 and keeping £16,000
of it what do you say to that
well that relationship with Virgin Media
started way back in 2020 where my father
was paid to uh be a judge um and judges
are often paid um was he paid yes and he
kept that money yes and that it wasn't
award ceremonies it was a community
Awards right so the first one I and I
was doing it with him because of course
he couldn't do it by himself um they
were about awarding a community um
Awards with virgin media that
relationship continued and they asked me
to keep working with
them by the time we evolved it they were
now Virgin Media ow to and all of those
discussions were happening even before I
was imagining being interim CEO so those
plans were already did you understand
why people I do and do you wish you
hadn't taken the money now I think in
hindsight what I should have done is
stalled that relationship either to
afterwards or just given the Mone to the
to the foundation yeah you were the
chief executive of the foundation the
the award was for your father right well
they were the Captain Tom
Awards I worked with Virgin Media to
ensure that the charity got some money
and recognition because I knew that they
would get huge recognition through
social media um and hopefully real
engagement with the charity for looking
at these for for seeing how the charity
was becoming involved in their War all
of which I think is completely valid and
and good good right just for the record
I think they're ex and the Ws the only
question is whether you should have
pocketed the cash I mean I again you
know I would say that looking at that it
doesn't look good you know you're the
chief executive of the foundation the
Foundation Award are in your father's
name to keep £16,000 just for turning up
and presenting a few Awards seems to me
to be the wrong thing to do do you do
you think that I think that it's all
very easy to look back and think I
should have made different decisions but
I hadn't planned on being the CEO and I
also only knew that I would I was only
ever there for three months at a time so
I didn't know if I would have employment
past those three months and I'm not in a
position where I can not work so for me
when we were planning all those dates
they may well have fallen in a period of
time when I wasn't the CEO that but
that's how it landed and and I
absolutely ensured that the charity got
a donation once you knew you were CEO
when you turned up with the awards and
you knew you were getting the money
wouldn't the better thing to have been
to just give it all to the foundation I
think the better thing to have done
would have been to push those Awards to
outside that period of time because I
was only ever going to be there for nine
months so I should have just pushed them
um forward or or or brought them in
advance but people will hear that and go
so you just wanted the money whereas
actually wouldn't I mean I don't want to
put words in your mouth M but for you to
look back and say actually I shouldn't
have taken that money it was wrong I
might be a better answer Ian I don't
tell you how to answer to these
questions because I'm the one asking
them but it makes it sound like that
that answer makes it sound like he just
wanted to cash but I think the reality
is that I have to work for a living and
um th that relationship with them was an
ongoing relationship and you were being
paid £85,000 a year for that job well to
to be CEO of the Captain Tom Foundation
were the Captain Tom Foundation Awards
well not to be too pedantic but I was
never gained to earn 80 because I could
never have been there for a whole year
no understand but that was the prata
rolling thre Monon annual deal right and
look absolutely in hindsight the two
things should have been separated the
the two things should have been
separated but that's not how it landed
and um that it was done with love and
with trying trying to ensure that the
community benefit benefited and the
Captain Tom Foundation benefited and yes
I got paid when when BBC News night
asked you about this you said via email
you are awful it's a total lie that was
your first response you then you then
said that um six minutes later you added
apologies that reply was for a scammer
who's been creating habit which is
absolutely true which is true but did
you did you actually give them any
clarification about the money why why
why were you Rel it because I I think
that we were being I probably received
well many many many emails trying to
demand information and we genuinely
wanted to make sure that when we do talk
that we talk on our terms and that we're
um we're saying it how it is and I
didn't think that was the right place I
can see that this has had a very
traumatic effect on you the whole thing
yeah the whole thing and the hatred is
brought the abuse that's brought you the
questioning of your
integrity the the diminishing as some
would say the reputation of your father
must be particularly terrible hurtful I
can see the effect it's had on and and
and I let me just pick up with Hann on
that I
mean articulate how it's been for you I
mean utterly devastating to think that
we had something that we thought could
make a global positive impact to be
devastated overnight because of course
when everything's POS positive and good
everyone wants to associate with you and
then when there's just a flicker of
Doubt all the people who are busy who
were engaging with us left literally
left it took a little bit longer for
things to flick into our business life
but suddenly contracts weren't being
renewed the foundation is probably never
able to recover from the foundation the
foundation is not able to recover the
trustees
don't want to close it you know and I
come back to what it's done to hannnah
in
particular I mean she has been extremely
ill and from the stress from the stress
extremely ill and we all have what's
your overriding message to to the world
because the world followed this
story I
think that we as a family we've ever
ever ever wanted to do was ensure that
my father's um Legacy has the greatest
possible positive impact on society
wherever that is and we felt that we
were really close to being able to do it
um and that has been taken away and yes
of course it's we're all judged on
hindsight um but what we have to
remember is where we were and how we
were making decisions was in a different
time we were operating at a th000 miles
an hour nothing ever felt that we had
any time or calm Essence to make
decisions so of course we can look back
and say some of those things should have
been done differently but I think give
us some credit for being human and that
we weren't an extraordinary family we're
just a family trying to do our best in
the circumstances we were plunged into
so of course we can look back and think
optically they that may look look not
look right but it was never our intent
to do anything other than work with my
father's Legacy to to give as much as we
could to the world and that allows
people far beyond my father's lifetime
or hours that allows people to touch
this incredible what would he be
thinking now looking down on what's been
happening to you well he would sit here
with us and say um I'm with them we
haven't been that family who's um tried
to take his legacy and make it for our
own gain we're trying our best we've
tried our best to do the right thing and
sometimes it's turned out it wasn't but
not through intent Benji what how have
you felt as your mom's boy you're 19 it
is just utterly devastating and to see
the impact has had on her and you know
people can have opinions that is up to
them but I what you cannot stand is
threats and abuse that are just vile and
the the difficulty she's had to go
through watching that as a as a son in
particular he's been UT devastated I
mean just to see your mom now tearing up
again but AB I mean there's been times
there's been genuine times where I don't
think she's known if she could go on and
I've sat there and thought that as well
but the the utter mental drain that it's
caused have you felt that way have you
felt like ending it all well no I'm my
father's daughter at the end of the day
um but it has been totally
devastating and I and it's all very well
say well this is what we try to do one
of the other really important important
things is we want to continue to do you
know we absolutely believe in this in a
world without agis and we absolutely
believe that Tom's Legacy needs to do
something going forward and needs is a
very important thing that we need to
keep going you know in the world George
what's it been like for you I mean no
young girl wants to see her mom like
this I know she's always trying to put
on a smile to make sure I don't really
know that much but I know it's really
draining for them all the time time
every single day even at night I know
that they're going to wake up with a
smile even if it if they're really
draining inside has it been tough for
you tough for seeing my parents and
family getting hate and abuse from
people inside the social media makes me
don't want to make go onto social
media well listen thank you for sharing
your time with me a lot of time you took
all the questions you said said you
would think it's important you did
people can make their own minds up it's
extremely tough clearly I can see from
your reaction and I'm I'm sorry to see
you like this all of
you thank you thank you thank you
appreciate time thank
[Music]
you
good evening I'm Pi Morgan uncensored in
New York City King pi and King Q I think
there's only room for one king man you
know what I'm saying he's mocked your
weight Trump yeah look at him fail not
working just cuz they're skin folk don't
mean they're kin folk do you believe you
can win this war making me cry again
they're trying to force you out yes I
feel betrayed keep it
award-winning Lucy Ley will die back
behind bars and a senior Doctor Who
first raised concerns about Ley wants
NHS manages to be regulated we needed
answers a lot sooner this is what 7
years down the line I mean it's
completely ludicrous he was clearly
something of the face of the ward so
even more Unthinkable if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a ward she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
weighty Katy that would make her a
better princess of wealth cuz you're not
just marrying the man you're marrying
the job that resonates with people gay
Maxwell agreed to be interviewed for the
very first time I he wish I'd never met
him the conservative party can certainly
win the next election can we lab
29 the
can did he say yes I have taken drugs
and they bent the rules or lied on the
visa application form and therefore got
it there needs to be an intervention
around abortion laws Parliament is
Sovereign Parliament can determine these
things the rest of the world has watched
on in sort of mounting horror as this
story has unraveled for you it was
incredibly personal the death toll from
the Titanic tragedy has risen to 1522
and may God Rest their
[Music]
souls Let It
Roll if we stop producing oil the knock
on effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know now you're probably going to
boot me off show
this Mar some of them they're easily
lit you can kiss my American
ass thank you very much very nice of you
Twitter you sons of can you please
reinstate my account thank you that's a
threat that you'd be worried of it so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with
us we're now in Barbie world you weren't
asked to give evidence to the grand jury
I'm